TSAHI LEVENT-LEVI: OK.
I'm Tsahi Levent-Levi, the
person behind BlogGeek.Me.
I'm going to talk now a
little bit about WebRTC.
I'm not going to go too
deep in the technical side,
because we only have 20 minutes,
and some of you know WebRTC,
some of you don't.
So first of all, thank you for
the opportunity for being here.
And I hope not to
bore you too much.
What we're going to talk
about first in 20 minutes
is what exactly is WebRTC?
What is it here to solve?
How does it achieve that?
The different types of
entities in WebRTC-- something
that usually people miss.
It's not only by having
something in the browser,
and you can run off
and do things with it.
You can, but not much.
And then if you want to
actually learn WebRTC,
where can you go to learn that?
Because I'm not going
to be able to achieve
that in these 20 minutes.
So what is WebRTC?
If you go and look for
the dictionary definition,
it will be something like that.
WebRTC offers real-time
communication running natively
from a web browser.
That's only part true,
and we'll see later why.
But that's, at least,
the nature of it.
And then if you come from
the Voice over IP space,
like me, then for
you, WebRTC is simply
a media engine that got
trapped with a JavaScript API
on top of it, OK?
So we have a standard API
on top a media engine--
nothing that interesting.
Something to remember--
WebRTC is only a technology.
It is not a solution.
I usually get questions like,
well, can WebRTC do this?
Well, it can, but not alone.
You need to add something
to it in order to get there.
You can't compare WebRTC
to a full service.
But you can build a
service on top of WebRTC.
So it is a piece of technology.
Whatever you do with
it, that's fine.
How are calls made with WebRTC?
We've got our two browsers here.
You'll see these logos
probably along this day a lot.
And we've got a web server.
Now.
The first browser is going to
send a message to the server.
This server is going
to send that message
or relay that to
the other browser.
Now.
This is a request-- an
offer-- to make a call.
The result is going to be
that the Firefox browser here
is going to send a response--
a line to that-- in answer
to the offer.
And that message is going to
get to that other browser.
Once that happens,
the magic begins.
And we've got this
line over here
that can send any type
of vibratory data.
It can be voice, video,
or something else.
Those of you that know Voice
over IP look at this and say,
well, that's SIP.
We know how to do that.
Nothing new here.
But if what you are doing is
web browsers and HTML code,
you look at that
and you say, well, I
could never send a message
directly across browsers.
This is fundamentally different
than how browsing or browsers
worked up until WebRTC.
And this is something
we need to remember.
Now, what goes on in 1, 2, 3,
and 4 isn't necessarily WebRTC.
It's just signaling, which
isn't a part of WebRTC.
Again, we'll see that later.
WebRTC comes with
three main API blocks.
The first one is GetUserMedia.
GetUserMedia allows you to
access from the browser using
JavaScript, your camera, your
microphone, or the screen
itself to capture the screen.
You can take that data and
do whatever you want with it.
Leave the other two.
Don't do anything with them.
You can now take
a photo of someone
and put it on his profile,
on whatever social network
you want to build with it.
MailChimp is doing that already.
So there are things
you can do with it
that don't relate to
communication at all.
Then you've got PeerConnection.
For me, PeerConnection
is WebRTC.
Everything that goes in
WebRTC goes in PeerConnection.
It gets you the signaling
stuff or at least the stuff
it needs to negotiate what
codecs are being used.
Is it only voice
call or a video call?
Is there a data channel there?
Is there more than a single
video channel, for example?
It sends that data
over the line.
It then codes and decodes the
stuff that you are sending.
It does everything.
And it deals with NAT traversal.
And then there's
the DataChannel.
The DataChannel simply allows
us to send whatever type of data
we want across
browsers without going
through any server
along the way.
These are the types
of APIs we have.
So why all the fuss?
We have a media engine.
Nothing new there, OK?
You can say that the codecs are
the latest ones, not the latest
ones, are better codecs.
But at the end of the day, it's
the same type of technology
that exists in any
videoconferencing solution
today and any Voice over
IP call that you make.
So what makes it so different?
First of all, it's free.
It's open sourced.
It is out there.
You can take it,
use it, compile it,
do whatever you want with it.
It's already-- let's call it
preinstalled inside browsers.
It's wrapped there,
so you can use it.
Before WebRTC, that
would have cost you
anywhere between
$50,000 to $200,000
just to start working with
it, not including royalties
that you needed to pay.
So that's a huge deal.
It's a reduction of barrier
of entry to new players
into this field.
If it was only that,
I would even be happy.
Coming from someone that did
in his past video conferencing
solutions, that's huge.
The second thing is even bigger.
This is for web developers,
not Voice over IP developers.
It is a huge difference.
I come from a Voice
over IP space.
I've got my upbringing.
There are certain
things that I know
how you do to build
Voice over IP solutions.
So my mind is already narrowed
to this kind of thinking.
There are lot many
other web developers
that don't have these kinds of
restrictions built into them.
And now we're unleashing this
kind of a solution to them.
So this is going to change
a lot of things out there.
Where is WebRTC happening today?
We've got Firefox and Chrome,
of course, supporting it,
also Opera, not included here.
But Opera is also one of the
browsers that support it.
And then you have Internet
Explorer and Safari
that don't have WebRTC
build into to them.
There are plug-in solutions
in these browsers.
But it doesn't come
natively from the browser.
In terms of the
history, Chris already
said, May 2011,
WebRTC was announced.
A few months later,
near the end of 2011,
we had the first browser
supporting WebRTC.
It supported only part of it.
It didn't really work.
The echo cancellation was the
worst ever, but it worked.
Now nothing happened in 2012.
That seems like a lost year.
But I started somewhere
in 2012 to actually look
at companies that do
things with WebRTC.
And from beginning
to end, we went
from a zero number of
vendors that use WebRTC
to 100 vendors that tinker
and build stuff with WebRTC.
And without having a
standard at that point
with a single browser that
almost didn't work with WebRTC
and changed consistently
the types of APIs
it provided, and still,
we had 100 vendors.
2013, we had Firefox on
board in second part of 2013.
We had mobile support.
Both Firefox and Chrome came
out with our Android support
for WebRTC.
At the end of 2013--
it's not here--
Opera provided WebRTC
on the desktop,
and later on at the
beginning of this year,
on mobile on Android.
If we look at mobile.
mobile is tricky for WebRTC.
I took the liberty of going
to the Google Play Store
and look at what gets
installed, what people download.
So you see the browsers here.
The purple are browsers that
don't have WebRTC support.
The green are browsers
that have WebRTC support.
And that's in the millions
or hundreds of millions.
That's not much.
We've got more than a billion
activations for Android today.
And the most popular
browser is somewhere here
at 300 million downloads.
And it gets forced
on users today.
So if you are thinking, well,
I'm going to build something.
It's going to run on
the mobile immediately,
because I've got it using
WebRTC on the web-- not going
to happen.
If will take more time for us
to reach there as an industry.
I've also taken
the liberty to look
at what other things
people download.
So anyone here has Candy
Crush on his phone?
OK, we've got only
three souls that
are actually telling the truth.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't.
But I get too many requests to
play Candy Crush on Facebook.
And then we have
Facebook and WhatsApp
messaging systems,
communication solutions.
And they are somewhere on top
of the 500 million downloads.
So today, WebRTC
on mobile is hard.
And I would say that at
this point in time, for most
of the use cases, it would
require an application.
So you'll take WebRTC,
wrap it in an SDK,
and then compile it
into your application.
You can still use
HTML5 inside that
in many different techniques.
And Google already
announced at Google I/O
that WebRTC is going
to be inside WebView
later this year with
Android L, so things
are improving and
improving fast.
But we're not there yet.
And we're not there yet even
in the terms of developers.
So yes, we're saying
web developers.
There is more web developers
than Voice over IP developers.
I took the liberty
to look at LinkedIn
and see how many people
there have WebRTC
in their profile--
almost 3,000 people.
Voice over IP--
more than 800,000.
So we're an abysmally small team
of people that look at WebRTC
and see that as
part of the things
that we know how to deal
with it-- not enough.
Going to another high
technology, big data--
not even a technology, only a
concept-- not even 1% of that.
So WebRTC is not hyped.
It is very small, and
it's growing nicely,
if you look at as time goes by.
Let's look at the
entities of WebRTC.
WebRTC, first and
foremost for me,
at least, is an implementation
of SRTP-- Secure Real-Time
Protocol-- with an SDP control
mechanism on top of it.
SRTP-- signaling protocol
that is used to send media--
voice and video, in this
case, and SDP is a way for us
to explain what it is
that we want to send.
I think that things
that exist in WebRTC
will have a media engine.
And then that media
engine will have
an implementation of three
codecs-- two voice codecs,
G.711 and Opus, and one video
codec, VP8, at least today.
In terms of the
VoIP implementation,
we are using in WebRTC
STUN, TURN, and ICE
to do NAT traversal.
And we need NAT traversal.
We'll see that in a moment.
On the client side, this
is what WebRTC gives you--
only this part.
The rest of the
slides in this area
are things that
WebRTC doesn't provide
but you need to have
in your network.
On the client side,
we have a browser.
Chrome and Firefox
supporting WebRTC.
So that's green for us.
Internet Explorer and
Safari don't support them,
can be solved with
plug-ins in the areas
or for the use case
that allow plug-ins.
Going on.
On mobile, Android browsers,
some of them support it.
Some of them don't.
So we are not
necessarily sure what
happens when we
want to run a use
case on mobile in a browser.
iOS browsers don't support it.
And you cannot support it
in an iOS browser today
because of the way the App Store
is built and the rules that
exist there.
And then you have SDKs and apps.
You can also always take WebRTC,
port it into iOS and Android,
run your application
on top of it.
And there are many use cases
that are already doing that.
If you want a PC
application, again, there
is the case that
it can run on a PC
and you can wrap your
application on top.
So you can do a PC
application if you want.
And if you want to go
for an embedded system,
you can again port
the SDK and use it.
So in terms of the
clients, you can
get availability in
many places with WebRTC.
None of them are, let's
say, the pure WebRTC,
which is only the browsers.
But we're talking about
real-life deployments.
And we don't really care
if the standard allows it
or not, or if that's
how it should be or not.
Signaling-- WebRTC comes with
bring-your-own signaling.
Whatever you want to
use for signaling,
this is what you're going to do.
It means the following.
If I want to reach out to you
and do a call with you, now
as a developer,
someone needs to decide
how that happens because I
don't know his IP address.
And for me to get that, someone
needs to negotiate that.
So I have a web
server in between
that does that negotiation.
That server can be
a social network.
It can be a website that
deals with e-commerce,
a blog, or anything
else that I want.
I can use different type
of signaling mechanism,
depending on what it is
that I want to achieve.
And I urge you to think
well before you decide
on the signaling mechanism
that you are going to use.
Usually, people will stop here.
And then we've got the
issue of NAT traversal.
And in NAT traversal,
there is this minor nuance.
Let me find it.
Let's see if I can run it.
If I check what's
my IP addresses,
it's 216 something--
blah, blah, blah.
[COMPUTER AD PLAYBACK]
We can close this one.
But if we actually check my
IP address, it's actually 192.
So I have two IP addresses.
One is an internal IP
address that only I know,
or the people within
my local network know.
And there's the
public IP address.
And if I want to reach
out to someone else
or if someone needs
to reach me, they
need to be able to know
my public IP address.
Otherwise, they can't reach me.
But I don't know that one.
STUN is a protocol that allows
us to solve exactly that.
It does a similar
thing to what I
did with a website
just a second ago.
You ask the question.
You go to a STUN server
that you know about.
You ask him, what's
my IP address?
You get a response.
And that, generally, will
create a pinhole in the net
where someone will
be able to reach me.
It doesn't always work.
But when it works, it's good.
And it doesn't takes a lot
of networking resources.
So most STUN servers
today are relatively free.
When that doesn't
work, we have TURN.
TURN will relay that
media through a server--
an external server that
will receive all of the data
and stream it to someone else,
to the other side because we
can't reach them directly.
So we went from a peer-to-peer
direct connection to a point
where we need to relay that
media through a server.
And that happens, well,
10, 20% of the sessions.
Again, it will depend on
the use case that you have
and the types of networks
you need to go and talk.
TURN is a bandwidth
hog because it
sends all the media through it.
And this is why these things
are usually secured and usually
don't open them
up for every one.
You will only install it and
run it for your own use case.
So we had signaling.
We had STUN and TURN servers.
We need to deploy
all these three.
We might need to deploy
other servers as well,
if we need to deal with
other kinds of media.
If I want to do a multipoint
conference with a large number
of people, I might need a server
to handle the load for that.
I can't do that on the
browser clients directly.
If I want to do
archiving, broadcasting,
or any other type
of media processing
that requires a
servers, then yes,
I will need a server to
be added to my solution.
WebRTC comes as a client
that runs on a browser.
And there are other
components that you
might need to add for your
use case on the server side.
Now, how exactly are we
going to learn WebRTC?
I am a book kind of a person.
And there are currently four
good books about WebRTC.
The first one is,
well, the WebRTC book.
Let's call this one the Bible.
This is the first book that
was written about WebRTC
by Alan Johnston
and Dan Burnett.
It is now in its third edition.
It is a very good book,
especially if what you like
is understanding
standards, and the details,
and the intricacies of
a specific protocol.
So that's the Bible of WebRTC.
Then there is the step-by-step
guide, written by Rob Manson.
This is a Getting
Started with WebRTC book.
It's a very good one.
It shows how you take
WebRTC, connect it
into a signaling server
based out of Node.JS,
which is what most of
the people do today.
And it just shows
how to do that.
So if you're one of these guys
that just want to get things
done fast, this is
the book for you.
The third book-- for me,
this is the living-room chat.
This is one by
Salvatore and Simon.
It's a new book from O'Reilly.
We have a few of
those here to give
as part of our raffle prizes.
I really like this book,
because it's natural.
Really, it's as if
one of these two guys
are sitting with you in the room
and explaining things to you.
So that the most
natural book for me.
The fourth one also a new
book-- WebRTC Blueprints.
This one is for
hard-core developers.
Don't open this book if you
don't know WebRTC already
and haven't started
playing with it.
It goes deep into some areas.
It leaves a lot
of things behind.
So use it with care, although
the information inside it
is pure gold.
You just need to understand
what you're doing with it.
If you don't like books,
and you rather look at URLs,
then there's the
HTML5 Rocks website,
which has several good articles
about WebRTC for beginners.
There's a WebRTC Hacks
website, with a lot
of stuff for developers.
Articles coming up every
few weeks with good content.
And there is the
discuss-webrtc Google Group,
where people ask questions
and Google actually answers.
Last but not least, there
is the WebRTC Weekly,
which Chris and I are running.
Go subscribe.
You will see weekly
links to things happening
on the internet that
relate to WebRTC.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
TSAHI LEVENT-LEVI:
What's Israeli in it?
There.
OK.
So thank you, and let's
move on to our next speaker.
[APPLAUSE]